[Música]
al menos dos decenas de personas han
perdido la vida a causa de los tornados
que han golpeado el centro oeste y el
sur de Estados Unidos miles de personas
se han quedado sin electricidad los
servicios de emergencia han alertado que
las cifras pueden aumentar con el pasar
de las horas
más de 4 millones de dólares recaudó la
campaña de Donald Trump para las
presidenciales en solo 24 horas luego de
conocerse que fue imputado en Nueva York
por presuntos pagos ilegales a la actriz
pornográfica Story Daniels
durante su segundo día de visita en
Guatemala la presidenta de Taiwán visitó
junto al presidente Alejandro yamaté y
las ruinas del Tikal la líder asiática
aseguró que esta nación es un socio
sólido en Centroamérica
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos en
Estados Unidos donde el sur y el centro
oeste están viviendo fuertes tormentas y
vientos con tornados en algunos estados
que han dejado al menos 21 muertos en
Arkansas la zona más afectada fue
decretado el estado de emergencia
mientras los equipos de rescate intentan
localizar víctimas y supervivientes
un fuerte temporal está causando
estragos en el sur y centro del norte de
Estados Unidos con varios muertos en
diferentes estados del país en Arkansas
un tornado ha causado un enorme destrozo
desde viviendas y autos arrasados hasta
árboles los equipos de rescate buscan
entre los escombros más víctimas o
supervivientes mientras los vecinos
están conmocionados
Conducir a través de un tornado fue muy
muy difícil nunca había experimentado
algo así en mi vida y como puedes ver
Hay un montón de cosas destruidas justo
en esta zona el servicio meteorológico
también ha emitido avisos de tornados en
otros estados como Illinois donde un
tornado hizo que el techo de un teatro
colapsara en pleno concierto
lo oí todo no vi nada pero lo oí todo
boom boom boom oí al otro lado de la
calle el edificio derrumbándose fue
terrible también en Indiana se ha
sufrido el temporal comienzos de hasta
100 kilómetros a por hora y al menos
154.000 hogares sin electricidad
en este momento para mí solo puedo
limpiar y luego tratar de ver a quién
más puedo ayudar y ver qué podemos hacer
para volver a poner todo en orden
todo apenas una semana después del
Tornado de Mississippi que dejó 26
muertos tras lo que el gobierno prometió
ayudar a la zona a recuperarse
el expresidente de Estados Unidos Donald
Trump comparecerá ante el tribunal de
Nueva York que el próximo martes el día
en que celebran los cargos y derechos
sin embargo estas acusaciones no
enturbian el apoyo de sus seguidores y
el juicio podría incluso jugar a su
favor para la campaña electoral de 2024
que ya recaudó 4 millones de dólares en
24 horas desde que se conoció la
imputación en su contra
Es la primera vez que un expresidente
estadounidense se enfrenta a cargos
criminales
Donald Trump comparecerá ante un juez la
próxima semana para ser procesado en un
tribunal de Nueva York El Magnate
enfrenta múltiples cargos de
falsificación de registros comerciales
durante su campaña de 2016 debido a la
forma en la que su organización registró
un reembolso hecho a su abogado Michael
cohen Que pagó a una actriz porno para
que ocultara una relación extra marital
que sostuvieron
creo que tiene que asumir la
responsabilidad de todo lo que ha hecho
es un problema de toda la vida siempre
ha hecho lo que no debía si hubiera sido
cualquier otro ciudadano estadounidense
habría estado en la cárcel hace mucho
tiempo
pero para muchos de sus seguidores los
cargos judiciales contra Trump no son
serios o no son tan importantes e
incluso refuerzan el incondicional apoyo
que le consagran Donald Trump recaudó
más de 4 millones de dólares para su
campaña electoral de 2024 en las horas
que siguieron el anuncio de su
imputación
[Música]
y creo que ellos los demócratas y el
sistema judicial lo están haciendo mal
no creo que quiero decir podría pasarme
a mí podría pasarte a ti podría pasarle
a cualquiera Y creo que da un poco de
miedo y la gente tiene que despertar y
ver esto en realidad creo que le está
ayudando creo que ahora va a conseguir
más votos porque la gente quizás se
despierta Eso espero
la seguridad fue reforzada en las
afueras de la corte de Manhattan pero
también alrededor del capítulo donde las
autoridades temen que un evento similar
al ataque del 6 de enero de 2021 tenga
lugar cuando alentados por él sus
seguidores irrumpieron en la sede del
congreso para rechazar el resultado de
las elecciones en las que perdió frente
a Joe biden durante el segundo día de
visita a Guatemala la presidenta
taiwanesa y el presidente guatemalteco
Alejandro yamate y visitaron a las
ruinas del Tikal sai catalogó al país
centroamericano como un gran Aliado en
la región cuando Taiwán Busca el apoyo
de la comunidad internacional para que
su soberanía que disputa con china sea
reconocida pero actualmente sólo tiene
el apoyo de 13 naciones a nivel global
Andrés triviño tiene los detalles
Taiwán es para Guatemala la única y
verdadera china Así lo aseguró el
presidente de Guatemala Alejandro
yamatei tras recibir la visita de la
presidenta taiwanesa inhuen con quien
realizó una visita al parque
arqueológico Tikal Fue un placer ver a
los amigos y compatriotas de Taiwán aquí
en Guatemala y presenciar los resultados
de nuestra asociación en áreas como la
agricultura Taiwán continuará trabajando
con sus socios y buscará un mayor
compromiso con el mundo la visita de la
mandataria es importante porque hace tan
solo unos días Honduras rompió 80 años
de relación bilateral con la isla
sumándose a Nicaragua El Salvador y
Panamá ahora Guatemala es el país más
poblado de los 13 que reconocen a Taiwán
como país soberano luego de celebrar 62
años de relaciones bilaterales entre
2013 y 2021 La Isla 90 millones de
dólares al país centroamericano tres
millones más que la Unión Europea y en
2014 el expresidente Alfonso Portillo
fue acusado de recibir un soborno taiwa
por 2.5 millones de dólares para
mantener la relación que muchos
cuestionan como lo hemos visto Costa
Rica El Salvador Honduras que tiene una
apertura también con con china creemos
que los demás países tienen que a tener
esa apertura también
la presidenta taiwanesa realizó una
escala en Nueva York antes de su llegada
a Guatemala acción criticada
enérgicamente por china ahora se espera
que visite Belice otro país que reconoce
a la isla
en Ecuador renunció el estado de
canciller Juan Carlos Olguín el
presidente Guillermo lasso confirmó la
dimisión que se produjo argumentando
motivos personales esta renuncia se
conoce a Solo dos días de que inicie el
juicio político contra el jefe de estado
y cuando la policía confirmó que el
viernes fue hallado el cuerpo de Rubén
cherres uno de los empresarios
Implicados En la presunta trama de
corrupción en empresas públicas que
originó el proceso contra el mandatario
cherres de 63 años fue encontrado con
otras tres personas y todos los cuerpos
presentaban signos de tortura en un
balneario de la provincia de Santa Elena
después de verse afectados por el
incendio que mató a 39 migrantes en
México Una familia de venezolanos ya se
encuentra en Estados Unidos a pesar de
haber logrado su propósito todavía
tienen que sortear varios trámites
legales Mientras tanto las autoridades
mexicanas dieron a conocer en la víspera
la captura del migrante que
presuntamente provocó el incendio Rafael
Pérez nos cuenta más
la imagen de vinagre Infante llorando
por su esposo dio la vuelta a los medios
del mundo
[Música]
su compañero Edward Caraballo uno de los
sobrevivientes del incendio que mató a
39 personas en un centro de detención de
migrantes ya está en suelo
estadounidense Caraballo fue trasladado
a un instituto sanitario en El Paso
Texas para seguir tratando el daño
pulmonar que le provocó la conflagración
vinagre Infante también inmuló la
travesía que esta vez se llevó a cabo de
manera autorizada ya Edward está del
otro lado Gracias a Dios lo logramos ya
lo recibió el lado americano ya está
próximo a llegar a la al hospital en
medio de la tragedia un final afortunado
Pues de valer la pena no Porque casi mi
esposo pierde la vida no Todavía faltan
varios trámites uno de ellos ante la
agencia de protección de aduana y
frontera de Estados Unidos Mientras
tanto las autoridades mexicanas cerraron
el emplazamiento migratorio donde
ocurrió el siniestro se ha tomado la
determinación de suspender desde ya Y de
forma definitiva la operación de la
estación migratoria de Ciudad Juárez
Chihuahua porque por lo que las personas
migrantes albergadas ahí se trasladarán
al centro integrador para el migrante
león a Vicario el migrante señalado de
presuntamente iniciar la conflagración
fue detenido era el imputado que faltaba
por aprender de las seis órdenes de
captura emitidas con relación al caso
fin del informativo volvemos en breve
[Música]